bonjour à tous comment vous allez bien
j'espère ça se passe bien aujourd'hui on
va se faire encore une vidéo plutôt pour
vous parler de vous de votre vie
numérique de qu'est ce qui se passe de
ce qui se passe de ce qui va de ce qui
va pas bien voilà alors là j'ai mis mon
joli casque parce que vous êtes en train
d'enregistrer sur le mont septembre de
podcasts je trouve qu'il ya un meilleur
son il ya vraiment meilleurs sont là
dessus je jouerai scene7 bg l'euro de
castor pro derrière avec les petits
effets et d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
avez écouté mon podcast si vous l'avez
pas encore découvert bien je vous ai mis
le lien en bas d'un description encore
un podcast très intéressant plein de
sujets plein temps de se raconter
aujourd'hui on va parler de la guerre à
des catalogues d'applications mobiles
qu'est ce qui se cache derrière tout ça
qu'est ce qui se trame qu'est ce qui va
arriver on ne le sait pas encore on va
le savoir très bientôt
en tout cas vous allez savoir en
écoutant fréquence grelots le podcast de
monsieur grrrr allez jeter une oreille
c'est pas un oeil c'est une oreille
parce que c'est un podcast essai de
l'audio et je prends beaucoup de plaisir
à le faire
il ya deux sujets pour le moment alors à
laquelle je tourne cette vidéo il y en
aura plein d'autres
il ya plein de sujets vachement cool et
en plus j'ai un petit effet c'est la
voie des lionnes qui vous passe un
message à bordeaux podcast damman papa
sinon gare à toi riez vous n'avez pas le
choix vous abonner bon alors aujourd'hui
on va parler d'un sujet qui est aussi
très intéressant c'est comment se
protéger contre le vol de son smartphone
je pense que vous le savez il ya rien à
plat d'ordinateur là y'a rien de bien
nouveau
et bien en fait on se fait voler son
smartphone je sais pas ça vous est
d'ailleurs vous déjà arrivé d'ailleurs
si ça vous est déjà arrivé marqué le
mois en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes déjà fait voler un smartphone
et si oui dans quelles conditions qu'est
ce qui s'est passé marqué le je pense
que c'est vraiment extrêmement
intéressant personnellement à l'heure
actuelle je ne suis pas encore fait
voler deux smartphones je touche du bois
j'ai cru du contreplaqué touche du bois
j'ai plein d'amis à qui c'est arrivé que
ce soit des vols à l'arraché ce soit des
vols sur une table sur un vol dans un
taxi ça arrive très souvent se faire
voler son smartphone et il faut être
extrêmement vigilant donc ce qu'on va
règne dans cette vidéo c'est eh bien
comment éviter déjà de se le faire voler
comment préparer sur smartphone
est-ce que vous ne perdiez pas tout si
vous vous le fait de voler ce aussi un
point extrêmement importante et puis on
va regarder également si vous vous
l'êtes fait voler qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire immédiatement pour venir vous
protéger et protéger votre abonnement
vous donnez votre carte sim et compagnie
mais avant toute chose et si ce n'est
pas déjà fait vous invite à venir vous
abonner à la chaîne regardée vous
cliquez en bas là vous avez un petit
bouton rouge vous cliquez vous actionnez
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
avec une nouvelle vidéo arrivera ça
c'est génial
alors on va regarder ça ensemble je leur
dis sous les yeux j'ai toutes mes notes
ce qu'il faut savoir
un premier temps c'est que si vous
faites voler votre smartphone il y a
très peu de chances que vous puissiez
retrouver que vous le récupériez et vous
puissiez reprendre je n'ai pas dire une
vie normale vous puissiez recommencer
une relation normale avec vos
smartphones
en règle générale qui dit smartphone
volley s'est perdue c'est oublier c'est
fini et ça il faut le savoir
il est donc extrêmement important de
prendre des précautions pour éviter de
se le faire voler et auquel cas si ça
devait vous arrivez ne pas se retrouver
complètement démunis et que vous
puissiez avoir toutes vos données une
fois de plus et ça c'est vraiment
important je vous ai mis un lien là sur
des statistiques de vol c'est un article
de la dépêche qui date un petit peu
c'est pas un article qui est extrêmement
récents qui date de 2016 mais qui vous
parle effectivement des statistiques en
vous disant qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on se fait voler son smartphone
quels sont les typologies personnes qui
sont plus à même de se faire voler c'est
assez intéressant je vous ai mis le lien
en bas vous allez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil
la première chose et ce qui est pour moi
extrêmement important c'est de minimiser
les risques
non pas que nous on est des conduites à
risques où on risque de faire voler son
smartphone en permanence mais les
voleurs sont habitués dans des
techniques ils ont des ruses et ils
repèrent facilement les smartphones on
peut facilement voler dites vous bien
que quelqu'un qui va venir voler vos
smartphones c'est quelqu'un qui en fait
un métier guillemets quand je dis ça
mais c'est vrai c'est un métier donc ils
repèrent leurs proies
il voit quel smartphone ils peuvent
voler facilement parce que l'idée c'est
d'en voler plein pour soeur un maximum
d'argent et si ça devient trop difficile
trop délicat où cas des risques et bien
ils vont pas forcément y aller donc
minimiser les risques
la première chose et c'est très souvent
à paris mais pas qu'à paris lorsque vous
êtes en terrasse ou buvez un verre avec
des amis
éviter de poser votre smartphone sur
votre table pourquoi parce que vous avez
quelqu'un qui va pouvoir arriver vous
êtes détendu vous buvez bien quelqu'un
va arriver tout va le prendre à
l'arraché m'appartient va courir vous
avez prié pouvoir faire ça c'est le
premier point vous avez aussi des
personnes qui vivent avec des pétitions
tubize ont regardé ma pétition venait à
signer qui voulait mettre sous votre
tête et qui oppose sa pétition et repart
avec le smartphone et vous l'avez même
pas vu venir et quand vous en rendez
compte et bien smartphones il est loin
s'est terminée il ya aussi tous les vols
à l'arraché vous avez vos smartphones
alors à guba vous passer un coup de fil
à un moment mon art est compliqué aussi
vous n'allez pas vous coller contre les
murs pour éviter qu'on vienne vous le
volet mais ça peut arriver les vols à
l'arraché si vous l'avez dans une poche
notamment une poche arrière dans les
transports en commun dans des lieux
bondés
on vous bouscule on vous le prend on
part avec ses pareils un sac à main ou
vert hop on glisse la main on part avec
faye a plein de technique qui évite donc
faites attention mettez le dans un
endroit un peu sécurisé vraiment les
poches contre vous sac à main ferme et
ses eaux mais dans une veine vous mettez
à l'intérieur poche fermé pour vraiment
venir éviter qu'on puisse vous
volley extrêmement rapide c'est vraiment
le premier point et c'est la base et
c'est très important il faut pas être
parano il faut pas se culpabiliser mais
il faut le savoir il faut en avoir
conscience
il faut faire attention le deuxième
point ça m'est déjà arrivé attention ne
soyez pas crédule je vous dis ça parce
que moi des fois ça peut être un peu
crédule jeune garçon plutôt gentil je
crois facilement ce qu'on vient de
demander je me rappelle j'étais à lyon
mais quelques années quelqu'un vient me
voir et d'écouter ce que vous pourriez
me prêtez votre téléphone j'ai vraiment
besoin d'appeler un ami je suis en
situation délicate
sauf que cette personne je la sentais
pas c'est difficile de se dire est ce
qu'on doit avoir confiance en une
personne ou pas alors quelqu'un au bord
de la route avec la voiture aux carafes
le capot levé bon je pense que vous avez
tous qui peut vous indiquer vous pouvez
en confiance mais imaginez quelqu'un qui
vient dans la rue qui vous dit vous
pouvez donner votre smartphone je peux
passer un coup de fil urgent vraiment
réussir à jauger la personne avant de le
faire moi je sais que t'es pas fait
parce que une fois de plus personne ne
la sentais pas ça m'arrivait deux fois
ça m'arrive également à clermont ferrand
on vient de perdre ton téléphone se
plaît j'ai un besoin urgent non et la
personne est insistante
donc il faut savoir jean non faut savoir
être ferme partir et ne pas donner son
smartphone parce qu'il faut que la
personne laurent vainqueur sera parti en
courant à moins que vous soyez un
sprinteur émérite vous risquez un moment
de vous faire avoir
attends je vais pas des choses qui sont
importantes à faire avant qu'on vous le
vol c'est d'activer la géolocalisation
c'est hyper important aujourd'hui tous
les smartphones vous le propose que ce
soit sur android que ce soit sur ios
vous activer la géolocalisation alors
c'est pas magique ça permettra dans les
premiers instants de votre smartphone
disparaît de pouvoir savoir où il est
alors pour le voir il faut aller depuis
son ordinateur pour vous connecter et
voir où il est et si la personne qui l'a
volée ne l'a pas éteint vous allez
pouvoir l'identifier savoir où il est et
ça pourra potentiellement aider les
forces de l'ordre et ça vous aidera
également si vous l'avez perdue comme ça
vous pourrez le retrouver
le quatrième point c'est de souscrire à
une assurance on nous propose beaucoup
d'assurance ans qu'on vient acheter son
smartphone au cas vous le feriez tomber
le cas où vous pourriez le cac cédant
plein de cas de figure ce que je vous
conseille c'est que lorsque vous achetez
un smartphone n'allait pas forcément
l'assuré immédiatement prenez le temps
d'y réfléchir mais ça peut être
intéressant si vous êtes dans une ville
où les smartphones se vole beaucoup
si vous êtes déjà fait voler un
smartphone si vous mettez beaucoup
d'argent dans un smartphone ça peut
valoir le coup de prendre une petite
assurance vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description pour aller jeter un
oeil
c'est un lien qui vous emmènera sur à
l'institut national de la consommation
et qui vous parlera des assurances en
règle générale c'est une fiche pratique
qui vous donnera plein de conseils et
d'astuces pour savoir un peu ce qu'il en
est en termes d'assurance ça peut
vraiment être intéressant le cinquième
point et qui est extrême
l'important est que vous devez faire
dans tous les cas que vous le père a dit
que vous le fassiez il faut vraiment le
faire faire des sauvegardes de votre
téléphone se regardait toutes vos
données
aujourd'hui vous avez des systèmes de
sauvegarde que ce soit sur un os avec
icloud vous l'avez également sur android
vous avez en drive vous avez plein de
solutions qui vous permettent de le
faire
sauvegardez votre téléphone dans le
crunch pourquoi pas ou même dans un
ordinateur en physique vous le branchez
sur son arrière une fois par semaine ça
vous permettra en cas de pépin de
pouvoir tout récupérer une fois de plus
c'est souvent quand ça nous est arrivé
qu'on est heureux de pouvoir tout
récupérer à d'ailleurs dit moi si ça
vous est déjà arrivé si vous avez pu
tout récupérer ou si vous avez pas pu si
vous avez tout perdu
marquez mémoires barreau commentaire le
sixième point c'est-à-dire sécurisé
quelqu'un qui vous vole votre smartphone
ce qui peut potentiellement cherché à
faire s'est il débrouillé pour voir s'il
ya pas d informations de carte bleue
l'information confidentielle qui
pourrait récupérer sur vous ce qui est
très important c'est de sécuriser
l'accès à vos smartphones mettait des
côtes pid compliqué deviner des codes
compliqué plus selon mieux c'est et si
vous mettez des schémas mettait des
schémas complexe pas des schémas très
facile à deviner le septième point noté
lee m e hisser le numéro
d'identification unique de vos
smartphones
ça permettra si vous le faites voler aux
forces de l'ordre de venir bloquer votre
smartphone pour la personne qui l'a
volée ne puisse pas l'utiliser en tout
cas sur le territoire européen pour
connaître votre imei vous l'avez soit
sur la boîte de vos smartphones soit
vous tapez le code comme si vous voulez
passer un coup de téléphone étoiles diez
06 diez et votre numéro 10 et mu
s'affichera vous l'enregistrer quelque
part vous le notez sur un papier comme
ça si vous avez un problème
au moins vous l'avez le huitième et
dernier point c'est d'utiliser des
fichiers cachés
si quelqu'un a une fois de plus volvo
smartphone arrive à craquer votre mot de
passe à passer au sud est arrivé dans
vos données et bien il existe soit des
applications soi-même en natif sur
certains os qui vous permettent d'avoir
des fichiers cachés
si la personne ne sait pas elle n'y aura
pas accès à toutes les données qui
peuvent être un petit peu cheap comme on
dit chez nous et bien vous allez les
planqués là dedans comme ça si la
personne a récupéré votre smartphone au
moins n'aura pas accès à ça voilà pour
les huit points importants pour venir
protéger vos smartphones contre le vol
maintenant je vous donnais des bonus des
petites choses à connaître la première
chose à faire si on vous a volé votre
smartphone c'est de contacter votre
opérateur pour qu'il vienne bloquer
votre carte sim c'est extrêmement
important une fois de plus la personne
arrive à déverrouiller vos smartphones
elle va pouvoir passer des coups de fil
dans le monde entier ça risque de vous
coûter une petite fortune
si vous n'avez pas à contacter votre
opérateur pour bloquer votre carte sim
et bien c'est vous qui allez devoir
payer tout ça deuxième bonus important
c'est de voeux
porter plainte extrêmement rapidement
sous 24 à 48 heures vous avez dans un
poste de police
vous portez plainte vous arrivez avec
votre numéro imei pour qu'ils puissent
identifier le smartphone afin qu'ils
puissent le bloquer vous devez d'arrivée
avec votre facture d'achat que ce soit
un smartphone neuf ou achetés d'occasion
ça c'est extrêmement important pour le
dépôt de plainte si vous n'avez pas ces
documents et bien vous n'allez pas
pouvoir aller bien loin
le dernier point qui est important si
vous êtes fait voler votre smartphone ce
que je vous conseille de faire
extrêmement rapidement
c'est de changer tous vos mots de passe
tous vos codes partout dans tous vos
accès en ligne soit sur votre adresse
email que ce soit pour votre code
bancaire que ce soit pour plein de
choses
vous me changer tout immédiatement ne
prend pas de risque il se peut que la
personne le vol juste les teignes et
qu'elle ne cherche pas à récupérer vos
données
mais si elle cherche à récupérer et
qu'elle peut avoir accès à vos données
et bien mieux vaut fermer toutes vos
sessions par exemple sur facebook pour
venir fermer toutes les sessions ça va
couper la session directement depuis
votre smartphone ça va éviter que la
personne vienne changer votre mot de
passe que vous ne puissiez plus y avoir
accès ça va venir vous protégez votre
compte google votre compte gmail c'est à
dire tous protégés et c'est extrêmement
important
au fond la course et quelques points
j'espère que ça vous aura apporté des
informations pendant tes croyez moi une
fois de plus c'est très important de
venir anticipé ces points là on y pense
souvent une fois que c'est trop tard que
le mal est fait et qu'on a perdu toutes
nos données laissent pas que ça va car
si votre sexe à vous ont rapporté plein
d'informations importantes par qui m'a
d'ailleurs tout ça en bas en commentaire
et dites moi vous si vous avez des
astuces a partagé concernant
l'anticipation du vol de vos smartphones
et même une fois qu'il a été volé
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire vous même
marqué en bas en commentaire ce
permettra d'enrichir le contenu sur ce
fait des gros bisous regardez je vous
remet un petit message d'elliot pour le
plaisir avant de presque 9 ans papa
sinon gare à toi exactement et c'est
valable pour la chaîne aussi à l'aise ou
s'embrassent à très vite pour fonder son
époux et bisous
[Musique]